Oh, ich habe vergessen, was zu trinken zu holen.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe vergessen, dass ich was zu trinken geholt habe.
Ich habe eine volle Flasche hier.
Reloaden hier auf der zweiten Seite.
So.
Anpel, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Excellent, excellent.
An das Trinken erinnern.
Ja, das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen früh.
Arul hat auch subscribed.
Habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ne, der war vor zwei Stunden.
Vor zwei Stunden.
Komplett random.
Pog.
Subscribers.
So, wenn man gerade dabei ist.
Ich mache mal eine VM an.
Eine Runde Package Updates.
Arch, by the way.
Da gibt es mit Sicherheit schon wieder neue Packages.
Da gibt es täglich neue Packages.
Weil Pleading Edge.
Chat-GPT kann kein Avalon.
Ja, Chat-GPT tut sich prinzipiell da eh ein bisschen schwer.
Was die Sharpcode angeht.
Habe ich zumindest den Eindruck.
Zwar.
Habe ich Chat-GPT mal gesagt.
Es soll eine Command-Line-Anwendung bauen in .NET.
Die einen Progress-Balken anzeigt beim Download.
Und da hat das für HTTP-Client einfach zusätzliche Methoden erfunden, die es nicht gab.
Und als ich Chat-GPT dann gesagt habe, ja das gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Dann hat es eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung generiert.
Auch mit Sachen, die es nicht gegeben hat.
Ganz super weird.
Allerdings.
Das war noch Chat-GPT 3.5.
Oder was war das letzte?
Ja, 3.5 wahrscheinlich dann.
Ja, Avalonia kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe da nur sehr wenig mit gemacht bisher.
Eigentlich nur ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und irgendwie 2-3 mal was im Stream gemacht.
Ich mache auch einen Bogen um Desktop-Anwendungen in letzter Zeit.
Avalonia, so cool das ist.
Ich mag diese XML-GUI-Geschichte.
Einfach nicht.
Einfach nicht meins.
So, machen wir mal Package-Updates.
Gibt es hier was Neues?
Aha, PyCharm hat es letztes Mal nicht updatet.
Okay.
Whatever.
Warum auch immer.
Man weiß es nicht.
Hier, Update.
Update.
Random Zeug.
Mr. S. N. Alive.
Dankeschön.
Massive Subscriber.
7 LQRS.
Was soll das?
7?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das...
Also, ich kann mir da keinen Reim richtigen.
Aber auch Dankeschön für fast ein Jahr Hyper-Subscription hier.
So.
Kernel-Update durch.
Dann machen wir hier nochmal.
Hier gibt es nichts.
Okay.
Ach, Lars war das.
Das ist schon ziemlich weit weg, dass man da einfach drauf kommen kann, oder?
Aber ich glaube, du hast das irgendwann schon mal geschrieben.
Chat, wir machen noch nichts Großartiges.
Ich sag's euch gleich.
Ich habe einfach mal den Stream angeschmissen.
Ich habe nichts Großartiges vor.
Ein bisschen schwätzen und ein paar Sachen angucken.
Guck mal, Pepo ist auch schon hier im Schlafanzug.
Jetzt mal das Allerwichtigste an.
Aski-Quarium einschalten.
Okay, nice.
Ich habe nicht mehr reingeguckt in letzter Zeit.
Was war denn da nochmal das Problem, was wir das letzte Mal hatten?
Ich habe es dem glücklicherweise auf Twitter geschrieben.
Einmal, dass man sich einfach einloggen konnte.
Was war das?
Was war das andere Problem?
Die Server-IP war public.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Also, es war...
Ich habe das Thema auf Twitter geschrieben.
Also, da kann ich nachgucken, was das gewesen ist.
Das Wetter?
Ich muss sagen, ich habe mich komplett daran gewöhnt, dass es so warm ist.
Das dauert immer so ein paar Wochen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch ist, ja?
Aber bei mir dauert das immer so ein paar Wochen, wo es mal richtig warm sein muss.
Dann gewöhnt man sich dran.
Ach so, ja gut.
Das kann ich ja umgehen mit irgendeinem VPN.
Oder...
Jumppost oder so.
Wie gehen da eh per Webinterface drauf?
Also, nachdem es jetzt ein paar Tage so richtig warm war,
habe ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Also, ich kann da auch nachts jetzt pennen und alles.
Ja, ich meine, es war jetzt die letzten Tage überall super, super warm.
Gut, vielleicht mal einen Tag unterbrochen.
Aber die letzten, letzten...
Ich weiß nicht, so eineinhalb Monate oder so war doch eigentlich durchgehend ziemlich warm.
Hast du davon schon gehört?
Nee.
Windows Update Downgrade Attack.
Unpatches fully updated.
Was soll...
What?
Nee.
Habe ich noch nichts von gehört.
Ja, aber ich habe die nachts nicht...
Okay, das stimmt nicht.
Manchmal mache ich die nachts an.
Aber ich kann auch so ohne pennen, ohne Klimaanlage.
Also, nachts habe ich die so gut wie nicht an.
Ich lasse die...
Ich mache die vielleicht, wenn es auch wirklich richtig warm ist nachts, lasse ich vielleicht
1, 2 mal 5 Minuten runterkühlen.
Aber das war's.
Macht dann wieder aus.
Ich kann aber nicht richtig bei pennen, wenn die Klimaanlage an ist.
Wo ich die Klimaanlage gern an habe.
Und dann auch den ganzen Tag teilweise über ist.
Hier im Arbeitszimmer.
Jetzt habe ich die auch gerade an.
Jetzt ist hier schön 24 Grad drin.
24, 24,2 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also sehr angenehme Temperatur.
Das ist vom Friseur ab und zu, ja.
Zug bin ich letzte Woche Mittwoch zuletzt gefahren.
Und da hat Ausnahms...
Weise, glaube ich mal, alles funktioniert.
Also, alles funktioniert bedeutet bei mir, der Zug kam plus minus 10 Minuten.
Ist ja abgefahren, wann er sollte und angekommen, wann er sollte.
In beide Richtungen.
Es gab natürlich wieder Probleme am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, dass an meinem Zug dran stand,
man sollte nicht einsteigen, obwohl das eindeutig der richtige Zug war.
Und irgendwie die keine...
Es ist, es ist also...
Der Tag, an dem wirklich mal gar nichts ist,
so dass wirklich alles ohne Problem...
Den gibt es nicht, den gibt es nicht.
Aber ich bin ja, ich bin ja schon, ich bin ja schon...
Zufrieden, wenn die Züge plus minus 10 Minuten fahren und, ja, ankommen.
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Das ist Thema und es wird wahrscheinlich auch noch eine ganze Weile Thema sein.
So sehr es mich abfuckt.
Willste machen.
Ja, dann sollen sie aber drin, dann sollen sie aber schon dran schreien, wenn die Türen offen sind, welcher Zug das ist.
Ich habe auch schon mal in einem Zug gesessen, der ist dann einfach in die falsche Richtung losgefahren.
Komplett Homeoffice?
Ja, sag mal so, ich würde, ich würde mich nicht wehren gegen Komplett Homeoffice.
Ich habe aber auch keine Schmerzen mit, dass ich einmal die Woche nach Frankfurt muss.
Übrigens, ich habe eine Telekom-Werbung gesehen letztens, hier bei mir im Ort.
Stand ganz, ganz groß, stand in der Werbung, das war Telekom, hat wirklich so richtig große Plakate und sowas gesagt.
Irgendwie, ja, da stand irgendwas drauf mit, jetzt Highspeed Internet.
Dann habe ich den QR-Code mal gescannt, da kamst du auf eine Werbeseite von der Telekom, konntest Verfügbarkeitsprüfung machen.
Und dann habe ich an der Stelle mal Verfügbarkeitsprüfung gemacht, wo ich das Plakat gesehen habe und was gab es?
VDSL 200.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ah, 250, 250, nicht 200, 250.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, warum macht man da für Werbung?
Das ist ja wirklich schon ein alter Hut.
Bei uns gibt es für alle, die Gigabit wollen, schon lange.
Flächendeckend über Vodafone Gigabit.
Wobei natürlich, so mal Glasfaser ins Haus das Beste wäre.
Also ich sehe jede Menge Ausbauten bei mir in der Nähe hier.
Warte mal, ich muss das Natur rausziehen, wieder reinstecken.
Ich sehe jede Menge Straßen, die aufgemacht werden und so wie.
Aber bei mir hier selbst nicht.
Und ich frage mich, wann sie es endlich bei mir auf die Reihe kriegen, Glasfaser zu legen.
Ich lasse mir das instant ins Haus legen, sobald es da ist.
Ich mache das, ich werde das auf jeden Fall nicht machen wie mein Opa damals.
Mein Opa, als die Kabelfernseher verlegt haben, hat damals gesagt, der Scheiß kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Und deswegen hatten wir wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das einzige Haus in der Straße,
was irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 50 Jahre später oder so, noch mal aufgebuddelt werden musste für einen fucking Kabelanschluss.
Also ich, ich grabe das denen selbst auf, wenn die das wollen.
Ja, ich buddel das selbst auf.
Hol ich mir einen Bagger, wenn es schneller geht, für Glasfaser buddel ich selbst auf, kein Problem.
Naja, das hat schon seinen Sinn, weil vielleicht Leute einen Glasfaseranschluss haben,
aber halt keinen, äh, kein Gigabit wollen und bezahlen möchten.
Ist doch sinnvoll, Glasfaser zu benutzen, wenn es da ist.
Besser alle mal und weniger Probleme als mit Kupfer, wirst du so oder so haben.
Ich würde selber buddeln.
Das Problem ist, dass selber buddeln dir alleine ja nichts bringt, du musst es ja irgendwo anschließen.
Sonst hätte ich schon längst Glasfaser gebuddelt.
Wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich das einfach, wenn ich das Problem damit lösen könnte, selbst zu buddeln, hätte ich schon gemacht.
Jaja, mal abwarten, was da passiert, wie soll das überhaupt funktionieren?
Ja, also das funktioniert, habe ich auch schon öfters jetzt gelesen, das funktioniert alles ziemlich gut.
Wer hätte es sich denken können?
Die bessere Technik funktioniert auch besser.
Hätte man nicht erwarten können vor 20 Jahren, oder?
Da siehst du, wann Telekom Glasfaser plant.
Okay, gucken wir mal hier.
Gucken wir mal Hanau.
Gucken wir mal, wie es in Hanau aussieht.
Äh, Hanau?
Nein, nicht Wolfstraße.
Wie zum Teufel kommt das Ding auf Wolfstraße?
Kann mir das mal irgendjemand erklären?
Einfach random irgendwas?
Ausgewählt, oder?
Ich habe noch nicht mal was eingegeben außer Hanau.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Wolfstraße.
Was bedeutet denn hier dieses...
Und die Farbe?
Was, was, was bedeutet denn das hier?
Max Adresse, ja Wolfstraße 4 liegt.
5G, ach das ist Mobilfunk, Festnetz.
VDSL weg, Glasfaser, Glasfaserausbau geplant.
Okay, also hier im Ort quasi gar nicht.
Wie, Hanau ist gar nicht geplant, oder was?
Hanau ist nix.
Guck dir das mal an.
Aber ich weiß, dass in vielen, also gerade hier in der Ecke, wird viel ausgebaut, aber nicht von der Telekom.
Also hier ist ja nix.
Guck dir das mal an, gar nix ist hier in Hanau.
Warum, warum gibt es denn so kleine Furzflecken, wo mal Glasfaser ist?
Guck mal, die haben hier, die haben doch nicht Glasfaser einfach für, für drei Häuser oder sowas.
Was ist das für ein Ausbau?
Ja, random.
Ja, random, zwei Häuser.
Das glaube ich doch, das kann doch nicht.
Stimmt.
Warum sind random einfach zwei Häuser angeschlossen, sonst nix?
Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Guck mal, sogar der Friedhof ist hier, zwei Häuser random wieder.
Das sind Neubauten.
Und warum hat das neu, aber, aber auch Neubauten brauchen ein Kabel in der Straße.
Was ist hier?
Ja, da wird auch neu geplant, okay.
Also in dem Tempo sehe ich ja da schwarz, das ist was wie ein, nix.
Aber es ist ja glücklicherweise nicht nur die Telekom.
Ich muss mal abwarten.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es bei mir gar nicht so eilig.
Ich meine, ich habe Gigabit Vodafone, Gigabit Kabelstelz, also ich würde sofort umsteigen auf Glasfaser, sobald es das gibt.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das unbedingt instant bräuchte.
Vodafone, bis auf so die kleinen Probleme, die es bei Vodafone halt immer gibt, so Frame Drops und sonst was hier Richtung Twitch.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Nein, bin ich nicht. Ich habe dann richtig
echt ein Dual-Stack.
Ich habe die auch hardcore geflamed lange
noch dafür.
Ich habe nicht mal ein Dual-Stack. Ich habe nur IPv4.
Oder?
Also ich habe kein Carry-A-Crate-Nut.
Ich habe entweder IPv4
plus IPv6. Richtig echter Dual-Stack
oder nur IPv4.
Ich hatte am Anfang auch Dual-Stack-Light.
Und das hat richtig viele Probleme gemacht.
Ich habe die einfach geflamed auf Twitter
öffentlich ganz lange, bis das dann
funktioniert hat.
Manchmal ist es ganz gut, wenn man
20.000 oder um die 20.000 Leute auf Twitter hat,
die das sehen, was man
liest, äh, die das lesen
und sehen, was man schreibt.
Das
sieht Vodafone auch und dann denkt sich
Vodafone, okay,
dann geben wir dem Max mal das, was er haben will.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was du mir
sagen willst, Bröselstein.
Also, wir sagen alle Einzelheiten
davon was, aber was das miteinander zu tun
hat, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, Vodafone hat schon so seine Probleme.
Aber es ist ja zumindest gut,
dass es die Möglichkeit gibt,
Kabel-Internet zu beziehen für viele
Leute in Deutschland, wo der Ausbau nicht so gut ist.
Aber warum wird es so ausgebaut?
Meint ihr, das sind auch so Leute wie mein Opa,
die sagen, Glasfaser,
das kommt bei mir nicht ins Haus.
Aber warum möchte
man 5G-Router benutzen? Das ist
Mobilfunk. Mobilfunk ist doch mal einfach der Sack
schlechthin für Internet
daheim. Ja, nice.
Ja, man muss die einfach nur ein bisschen nerven.
Ich finde sie auch sinnvoll.
Weil die meisten Leute
haben damit kein Problem. Oder wenn sie
Probleme haben, checken sie nicht, wo es liegt.
Ob mein Vater jetzt DS Lite hat
oder nicht, das juckt den überhaupt nicht.
Aber für Leute, die damit was machen wollen
und Probleme haben, ist es gut, wenn die das freischalten.
Ich habe übrigens noch kein BIOS-Update
gemacht. Jemand von euch,
hat jemand von euch eine 13. oder 14.
CPU-Generation von Intel
und hat schon BIOS-Updates gemacht, wegen
dieser Spannungs-Micro-Code-Geschichte?
Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht.
Ach so, nur weil es so viel Zeit ist.
Ach so, ja gut. Wenn es natürlich nur
5G gibt, dann ist es sehr geil.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, zu
Battlefield 3 Zeiten, wo die Server
in Frankfurt und Köln standen, wo ich
teilweise einen 6er und 7er Ping hatte
zu den Servern. Das war nice.
Das war geil.
Muss man die neu machen? Also ich bilde mir ein,
ich kann irgendwo im BIOS
die Settings speichern und dann
restoren. Es kann natürlich sein, dass es nicht
funktioniert, weil sich so viel geändert hat.
Muss ich erst mal gucken.
Gibt es irgendwo in dem BIOS, gibt es da
wie einen Diff? Was ist meins, was ich mehr
habe als Default?
Weil ich weiß doch gar nicht mehr, was ich da
alles eingestellt habe.
Alles weg beim Update.
Ja, ich spiele regelmäßig Sachen.
Der hat nichts. Also was ich gar nicht
mehr spiele, ist Call of Duty und Battlefield
2042 habe ich auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr
angefasst. Es gibt in der Tat
in den letzten Jahren zunehmend
relativ wenig,
also zunehmend weniger Spiele, die mich
wirklich begeistern.
Oftmals ist es irgendwelchen Kleinkram,
also es gibt, okay, sagen wir mal so,
es gibt nicht wirklich, es gibt,
das stimmt nicht, dass es weniger Spiele gibt, die mich
begeistern. Es gibt insgesamt immer noch genug Spiele, die mich
begeistern. Es gibt zunehmend
weniger von den richtig großen
Titeln, die mich begeistern.
Was habe ich mich früher gefreut,
wenn ein neues Call of Duty rausgekommen ist?
Oder wie habe ich mich gefreut, wenn ein neues Assassin's Creed
rausgekommen ist oder sowas in der Richtung?
Mittlerweile, die letzten paar Assassin's Creed
haben wir gar nicht mehr gekauft.
Und
das letzte Call of Duty habe ich auch nicht mehr gekauft.
Und ich habe mich davor schon einige
auch ausgelassen.
Elden Ring habe ich
gekauft zu Release auf Steam.
Das war es aber auch, dabei ist es geblieben.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan
der Souls-Spiele.
Es ist nicht meins.
Deswegen habe ich mich immer davor gedrückt, das hier Elden Ring zu
spielen.
Was ist denn mit dem Benefee-Klon?
Nix. Als ich gesehen habe,
dass da Bots als
echte Spieler verkauft werden, habe ich keinen Bock.
Außerdem wird das, das habe ich
mir auch gekauft.
Aber habe ich auch noch nicht gespielt.
Generell besteht meine Steam-Library
zu 70% aus Spielen, die ich
cool fand, weil sie nice aus...
Weil ich dachte, die sehen cool aus
im Shop. Habe ich die ja gekauft
und habe die nie gespielt.
Ich glaube, ich habe mindestens die Hälfte
meiner Steam-Library noch nicht
gestartet.
Dafür habe ich total viele Stunden in Games, die keine Sau kennt.
Was ich an Elden Ring...
Beziehungsweise, ich weiß nicht, ob es in Elden Ring auch so ist,
aber ich denke mal, was ich
an Souls-Spielen nicht mag,
ist, ich sage mal,
diese Behebigkeit.
Wobei ich das an sich nicht schlimm
finde, sondern diese...
Du drückst eine Aktion
und musst warten, bis die Aktion fertig
ist. Und ich weiß nicht, irgendwie fühlt sich
das so... so behäbig
an.
Overwatch 2, ganz ehrlich,
ich habe es nicht mal installiert.
Nachdem mich Blizzard da so enttäuscht
hat, wie sie umgegangen sind mit
Overwatch 1.
Overwatch 1 hatte ich ja auch...
Boah, keine Ahnung, wie viele Stunden,
Alter.
Mehrere Accounts.
1000 plus...
Ach, das reicht nicht.
Das reicht nicht.
1000 hast du ja relativ... 1000 hatte ich wahrscheinlich schon
in der Beta.
Kann man in Street Fighter beispielsweise auch nicht.
Nicht gescheit.
Und...
Also, wenn man es auf die Reihe kriegen will.
Und du bist trotzdem nicht
zwei Sekunden gelockt.
In irgendeiner Attack-Animation.
Also, mir gefällt...
Das ist eines der Sachen,
die mir an Souls-Spielen bisher nicht gefallen hat.
Was ich mag an
Souls-Spielen ist der Soundtrack.
Die Optik, die Atmosphäre.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich mir
noch nie was zu angeguckt.
Ich höre sogar an den Soundtrack.
Den Dark Souls-Soundtrack ab und zu.
Random. Obwohl ich mit dem Spiel nix am Hut habe.
Ja.
Es wäre nice gewesen, hätte mich Overwatch 2
interessiert, aber nach der
Entwicklungsgeschichte, nach dem, dass die ganzen Leute vom Team
weggerannt sind, wie Blizzard Overwatch 1
verkackt hat...
Ich hab's nicht von mir installiert.
Ich hab nicht eine Minute Overwatch 2
gespielt.
Und ich hab's noch nicht vor.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie läuft denn das so?
Twitch? Overwatch 2?
Ist das noch semi-beliebt?
Was zum Teufel ist mit...
Mit Twitch kaputt, Mann?
Wie... Alter...
Okay. Karussell-Raster?
Ich will das nicht.
Ich will das nicht anschauen, Leute.
Ich möchte einfach nur sehen...
Seit wann ist denn die Seite so scheiße?
Früher hast du hier einfach eine Übersicht gesehen
von allen Leuten in dieser Kategorie.
Seit wann ist denn diese Seite
so unbrauchbar kacke geworden?
Ah, ein paar spielen das noch.
Reingezoomt?
Moment. Die Seite wird einfach
ab einem 150er Zoom-Level unbenutzbar
kacke? Verstehe.
Gagwaits.
Aber ich muss soweit reingezoomt
bleiben, weil sonst der Chat zu klein ist.
Ja.
Mobile first.
Dynamic. Nee, wie heißt das?
Wie heißt das? Design.
Responsive Design.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es reine
First-Level-Problems sind, wenn eine Webseite
nichts mehr anzeigt, was man sehen will.
Ich würde sagen, das sind
All-World-Problems.
Übrigens, mein Vater hat mich vorhin angerufen.
Das war mal als kleines Update.
Er benutzt immer noch Linux Mint
und kommt mit klar. Also sprich,
das ist jetzt, glaube ich, sein dritter Monat oder sowas
mit Linux Mint.
Und es funktioniert einfach. Gut, der macht
ja auch nix. Der macht einen Browser auf
und das war's. Vorhin hat er mich angerufen
und hat gefragt, wie er Word draufkriegt.
Und warum braucht er Word?
Weil er eine
Einkaufsliste schreiben will,
die einer seiner Pfleger
ihm kauft, einkaufen
soll. Da habe ich ihm gesagt, du brauchst
kein Word.
Mach einfach LibreOffice
auf. Und da hat er das aufgeschrieben.
Aufgemacht. Und wisst ihr, was
das Erste war, was er gesagt hat?
Er hat gesagt, das ist
Wim!
Ja, das wäre es
gewesen. Macht mal Wim
auf, Papa.
Das Erste, was er gesagt hat, ist
sinngemäß sowas wie, das ist doch Word.
Ja, genau.
Sowas hat er gesagt.
In der Richtung. Ich kriege den Wortlaut nicht mehr genau hin.
Er hat sinngemäß gesagt,
das ist doch Word.
Und dann hat er vorgelesen, was da steht.
LibreOfficeWriter.
Und dann hat er gemeint, Libre heißt doch
sowas wie kostenlos.
Ja, das ist alles kostenlos.
Outlook, nö.
Der benutzt E-Mails nur im...
Niemand, ganz ehrlich, die ganzen Casual-Leute,
niemand braucht da Outlook von.
Die Leute gucken sich E-Mails an, das sollen die
in irgendeinem Webclient von ihrem E-Mail-Anbieter machen.
Manche Leute, die Outlook ein bisschen
intensiver benutzen mit Kalender
und allem. Aber dann brauchst du ein Smartphone-Sync.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit,
gezwungenermaßen, auch Outlook und ich mache damit
nur ab und zu mal E-Mails,
alles markieren, gelesen.
Zack.
Das war's, mehr mache ich mit Outlook nicht.
Ich fake, dass ich alle E-Mails
gelesen habe. Ansonsten
brauche ich das nicht.
Obwohl ich ja ein Outlook-Abo habe.
Ich habe ja ein Office 365-Abo.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mich da geritten hat.
Doch, ich weiß es, was mich geritten hat.
Die 2TB
OneDrive-Storage haben mich geritten.
Seitdem, warum mache ich eigentlich
zum fünften Mal ja schon ein Betriebssystem-Update?
Und ich weiß auch, dass es nix gibt.
Seitdem
habe ich ein Office-Abo. Und das kostet ja auch nicht viel.
Das kostet, was kostet das im Jahr?
20 Euro oder so? Keine Ahnung.
Billig.
Was kostet ein Office 365?
Subscription.
Ach, sorry.
Microsoft 365.
Kost? Ja,
70 Euro im Jahr.
Moment.
Leute?
Auch nur 1TB Cloud-Speicher?
Oder war das früher 2TB Cloud-Speicher?
Ich habe im Hinterkopf, dass es mal 2TB Cloud-Speicher war.
Dass ich 2TB Cloud-Speicher habe.
Vielleicht täusche ich mich aber auch.
70 Euro im Jahr
bezahle ich wahrscheinlich gerade.
Hä?
Du hast dir bestimmt
früher auch ganz legal
Adobe Photoshop-Keys
gekauft.
Oder noch besser.
Macromedia Dreamweaver.
Bestes.
Bestes einfach.
Wer es kennt, der kennt es.
Haben wir noch
irgendwelche Dreamweaver-Enjoyer hier?
Oder besser gesagt,
nicht haben wir noch,
haben wir hier
ehemaliger Dreamweaver-Enjoyer?
Also ich bin eindeutig
ein Dreamweaver-Enjoyer.
Beste.
Dreamweaver hier.
Macromedia
Dreamweaver 8.
Beste, Leute.
HTML-Editor 2000, darum.
Beste.
Die FRAPS,
ja ey, ich werde es nie verstehen,
warum sich FRAPS überhaupt so durchgesetzt hat.
FRAPS hatte entweder
viel zu große Performance-Dinger
für die damalige Zeit
oder eine scheiß Qualität und
das war schon immer Schrott eigentlich.
Jo, was geht? Ich bin bald fertig mit meiner Physi-Ausbildung.
Sehr gut, kratz.
Wie man in MMOs früher gesagt hätte.
Heutzutage,
das ist auch ein bisschen komisch,
in MMOs hat sich
mittlerweile auch GG durchgesetzt,
was total bescheuert ist
für MMOs, ja.
Früher war das so,
irgendjemand, keine Ahnung,
Level-Up gehabt,
45 auf 46, da haben die Leute
früher geschrieben, kratz, oder
die Leute, die faul waren, haben
GZ geschrieben, ja.
Manche haben auch geschrieben, kratz,
oder so. Naja, zumindest,
heute
schreiben die Leute GG.
Was überhaupt keinen Sinn macht im
MMO-Kontext
eigentlich.
Naja, komm mal zu dem rüber,
was du eigentlich fragen willst.
Ich bin bald fertig mit meiner Ausbildung zum Physi.
Ja, wie gesagt, kratz.
Und habe keine Ahnung, was...
Achso, wenn du bald fertig bist,
heißt das, du hast jetzt Abschlussprüfung?
Weil die sind ja so in dem Dreh jetzt.
Ende August,
so von jetzt bis Ende August
sind die. Und habe keine Ahnung,
was danach ich genau machen will.
Ich bin bei einem Dienstleister und möchte
irgendwas mit Linux Cyber Security machen.
Hat jemand Tipps, wie ich mich orientieren kann?
Boah, das ist natürlich sehr schwierig.
Wir sind ja nicht du.
Gab's denn in der Ausbildung irgendwas, was
dir besonders gefallen hat? Und die Frage ist,
willst du bei deinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber
bleiben, oder nicht?
Beziehungsweise darfst du bei deinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber bleiben?
Will der dich weiter behalten?
Und wenn ja, wenn er dich weiter
behalten will, dann hat er doch bestimmt
schon auch eine Vorstellung, wo?
Und deckt sich diese Vorstellung
mit deinen Vorstellungen?
Was mit Linux ist aber auf jeden Fall
eine gute Wahl. Ich mache auch was
mit Linux. Ich verdiene auch schon seit
nicht ganz, aber mittlerweile
sind es fast 20
Jahre mit Linux Geld.
Mein Geld. Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass das so lang schon
ist, gell?
Krass. Fuck, Alter.
Fast 20 Jahre.
Ja.
War auf jeden Fall die richtige Wahl,
mich damals, und das war damals
auch schon relativ Nische noch,
war auf jeden Fall die richtige Wahl,
damals mich mit Linux zu beschäftigen.
Und ich habe Glück gehabt, dass ich bei einem Internet-Provider
gelandet bin, wo es hauptsächlich
drum ging,
wo es hauptsächlich um Linux und
Linux-artige Umgebungen
ging.
Das zahlt sich heute aus.
Mein persönlicher Eindruck ist,
dass man Linux-Leute mit Know-How
zwar auch gut findet, aber
schwieriger
findet, als
3000 Windows-Leute,
die an jeder Ecke warten.
Wo neues Video bei mir im Kopf
beifährt.
Klingt wie ein Name, den ChatGPT generiert hat, oder?
Hallo ChatGPT,
ich möchte eine Firma
aufmachen, die was mit Linux, Computer
und Security zu tun hat.
Dann sagt ChatGPT CyberSec24.
Diese
Sache mit 24 in Namen schreiben,
ist doch eigentlich schon wieder
komplett out.
Genauso im Jahr 2000 rum und davor
hat sich jeder Laden irgendwas mit
2000 genannt. Die waren dann richtig
gearscht, glücklicherweise wird der Tag
auch weiterhin 24 Stunden
haben.
Da waren die alle damals gearscht,
als die 2000 im Namen hatten.
2000 war halt irgendwo mal super
zukunftsorientiert, aber nach 2000
war 2000 halt nicht mehr zukunftsorientiert.
Manche waren super
kreativ und haben sich einfach in 3000
umbenannt. Manche haben es einfach
weggelassen und viele sind pleite gegangen.
Was aber wahrscheinlich nicht am Namen lag, sondern dass das
eh Kackfirmen waren,
die was mit 2000
im Namen hatten.
Ist aber eine gute Firma, sehr netter Inhaber.
Ja, glaube ich dir, glaube ich dir.
Ich finde der Name klingt bloß so ChatGPT mäßig.
Döner 2000
gibt es doch in Wiesbaden.
Das ist nicht der, wo das nur noch 350
kostet, oder? Da gibt es doch irgendwo so eine...
Wo ist denn das?
Welcher Stadt ist das? Es gibt doch irgendwo so eine
legendäre Dönerwand, wo irgendwo
so einer mal hingeschmiert hat
Döner 250 oder so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welche Stadt
das ist, das ist irgendwie deutschlandweit berühmt.
Weil da irgendwann mal einer Döner
250 oder so geschrieben hat.
Echt, Office 365
funktioniert nicht? Tja.
Mit Linux
wäre das nicht passiert.
Doch, wäre es auch.
Office 365 mit Linux würde auch nicht funktionieren.
Warum funktioniert
das nicht?
Ganzer Tag ist ganz schön viel.
Cringe Joke.
Ja.
Kann sein, dass es das ist.
Ich weiß nicht, es gibt, habe ich schon öfters auf Reddit gesehen,
dieses komische, komische Wand,
wo irgendeiner mal drangesprayt hat
Döner 250.
Mittlerweile, boah ey,
das ist super teuer geworden, ne?
Ich war in Frankfurt letztens
in einem Dönerladen.
Ich muss dazu
sagen, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht. Das ist kein
Dönerladen, das ist eigentlich ein Laden, wo es Köfte gibt.
Das sind türkische Frikadellen
im Endeffekt.
Also eigentlich sind es Frikadellen.
Ja, kann man sagen. Sind eigentlich Frikadellen
mit ein bisschen Spezialgewürz, aber ansonsten sind es
Frikadellen.
Ich esse da immer
Hähnchenbrustfilet
Teller. Das sind im Prinzip
gegrillte Hähnchenbrust
Teile und, nein!
Der Teller hat gekostet 14 Euro.
Und dann noch irgendwie
3 Euro für eine Flasche Wasser.
Oder so was dabei. Oder 2,50 für eine Flasche.
War echt, war echt,
ist echt teuer gewesen mittlerweile.
Ja, ja.
Also in Frankfurt Mittagessen
ist, das ist normal. Das ist nicht, das ist
nicht mal, das ist nicht mal übertrieben teuer.
Ja, Kaiserstraße
kriegst du wahrscheinlich für die Preise, ja, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob du das haben willst.
Also wenn du da
in diese Ecke rumläufst,
die Leute, die du da siehst,
die willst du eigentlich
nicht an dich ranlassen und schon gar nicht.
Äh,
an solche sensiblen
Stellen lassen.
Dann hast du Ausschlag danach.
Aber es ist billig.
Geh ich mal von aus. Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber die Leute sehen so fertig aus. Wir haben doch letztens zusammen
einen Frankfurt-Rundgang gemacht, Leute.
Hier. Auf Google Maps.
Da sind wir da auch lang gelaufen.
Da habt ihr doch die ganzen Spezialisten
gesehen. Auf der Straße.
Ja, das ist, das ist,
es ist echt wirklich übertrieben teuer.
Deswegen bin ich sehr froh da drüber.
Erstens, Homeoffice.
Prog. Nach wie vor.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Die Kombination.
Ich hätte das früher, ne, ich muss
ich muss anders anfangen.
Und zwar,
ich kann mir es gar nicht mehr
vorstellen, wie ich das
früher geschafft habe,
die Kombination aus
fünf Tage die Woche
nach Frankfurt
acht Stunden
am Tag mit
dem Zug hin und zurück
jeden Tag
und als ich noch in der alten
Wohnung gewohnt habe
mit dem Bus zum Bahnhof.
Wie habe ich das überhaupt
geistig ausgehalten?
Da gab es gefühlt, also ich meine, es war nicht
es war zur damaligen Zeit noch
nicht ganz so beschissen wie heute.
Die Bahn ist ja quasi auch statistisch gesehen immer schlechter geworden
in den letzten Jahren.
Aber es war auch schon kacke.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das ausgehalten habe.
Morgens so früh aufstehen.
Ich bin 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden.
Also ich habe wirklich keinen Plan.
Keinen Plan, wie ich das, wie ich das
Ja, ich meine, man gewöhnt sich
man gewöhnt sich auch an viel, an viel Shit, ja.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich das gemacht habe.
So, und heute, Leute, es ist einfach
die beste Kombination ever.
Ne, die Arbeit hat auch nicht richtig Bock gemacht.
Am Anfang, wie gesagt,
war ich ja noch, sagen wir mal
zu meiner Azubi-Zeit, ja.
Da war ich in Frankfurt
bin ich nach Frankfurt morgens gefahren.
Dann bin ich erstmal, habe ich erstmal Rundgang gemacht
durch unsere Standorte.
Rechenzentrum-Standorte.
Und ich habe euch schon öfters
erzählt, dass ich gerne im Dunkeln durchs Rechenzentrum
gegangen bin und absichtlich ohne Licht
und ich quasi schon an jedem
Lämpchen erkannt habe damals,
wenn irgendwo was anders aussieht als gestern.
Das ist tatsächlich
eine Sache, die würde ich gerne mal wieder machen.
Also Chat,
wenn einer von euch
irgendwas hat
in Frankfurt,
ich komme vorbei und baue euch ein paar Server ein.
So, so ein bisschen
Rechenzentrum-Bastel-Kram würde ich gerne mal wieder machen.
Ich war, ich war, also,
das hat sich schon ganz schön gewandelt, gell.
Überlegt mal, ich war früher
jeden Tag mehrfach
im Rechenzentrum
und jetzt war ich bestimmt
ein Jahr gar nicht mehr drinnen.
Ich weiß, ich weiß von meinem
aktuellen Arbeitgeber nicht mal mehr genau,
wo das ist überhaupt.
RGB-Streifen. Wir hatten mal
einen Server bei uns im Keller laufen, das war so
eine Team...
Team-Share-Kiste,
ja, wo wir uns damals so
semi-legal drüber getunnelt haben,
dass wir kein VPN benutzen mussten.
Der war case-modded.
Solch ein case-modded Server.
Der hatte so Leuchtstoffröhren und sowas drin.
Warum? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab das zum ersten Mal gesehen, als ich das Ding aufgeschraubt
hab und reingeguckt, hab festgestellt, da sind
Röhren drin, irgendwie. Irgendeiner hat das Ding
case-modded.
Das war doch kein RGB, das war doch so
Leuchtstoffröhren oder sowas,
die da drin waren.
Pre-RGB-Strip-Zeit, das war, keine Ahnung,
2008 oder so.
Da hat noch keiner an irgendwelche RGB-Strips
gedacht. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum
das ein case-modded Server war.
Bis heute nicht.
Ja, was sonst?
Ja.
Riesenunterschied. Ja, also.
Ja, ich mache noch Home-Office. Bei mir sieht das
aktuell aus, dass ich
drei Tage die Woche
Home-Office mache und einen Tag die
Woche auf die Arbeit nach Frankfurt fahre.
Im Durchschnitt. Manchmal auch zwei Tage
und dann vier. Aber
im Durchschnitt einen Tag die Woche.
Und dazu arbeite ich ja noch Teilzeit.
Das sind ja auch nur noch
quasi dann
vier Tage arbeiten, drei Tage frei.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was bei Teilzeit immer
ein bisschen runter, bei der Überlegung
runterfällt. Es ist nicht nur
so, dass du einen Tag weniger arbeitest.
Du hast, oder sagen wir mal so,
es ist nicht so, dass du nur
einen Tag mehr frei hast, du arbeitest auch
einen Tag weniger.
Also du hast einen Tag mehr frei, aber
du musst auch einen Tag weniger arbeiten, was dazu führt,
dass du quasi
erholter bist
und die Woche wieder schneller vorbei ist.
Das rechnen viele Leute,
glaube ich, auch falsch.
In meiner Rechnericht ist es easy zu rechnen.
Aber der Erholungsfaktor von
einen Tag mehr frei
und einen Tag gleichermaßen weniger arbeiten
und die Woche ist schneller vorbei, ist höher
als wenn
die Woche einfach nur einen Tag weniger hätte.
Wisst ihr?
Und jetzt ist es wirklich super angenehm.
Drei Tage lieber Home-Office.
Ich muss mich nicht mit der scheiß Bahn
herum ärgern.
Wenn ich fertig arbeiten bin, bin ich am Start.
Ich kann eine Laufrunde machen.
Ich kann nachmittags noch
zwei Stunden Fahrrad fahren gehen.
Ich
hab kein
dummes Rumgesitze
mehr irgendwo in der Bahn, wenn
irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Und es funktioniert auch alles viel besser.
Ich krieg daheim schlicht und ergreifend
mehr geschafft als auf der Arbeit.
Ich merk das immer.
Meistens fahr ich mittwochs nach Frankfurt
und an diesem Tag, es passiert nichts.
Vielleicht erkennt sich da irgendjemand
wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch aussieht.
Echt? Boah.
Shitlab wird verkauft.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist,
aber ich habe immer
also mittwochs, wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahr,
ich kriege nichts auf die Reihe.
Mein Mittwoch besteht aus
Wo hab ich denn mein Handy? Pass mal auf.
Diesen Mittwoch.
Ich sag euch mal, wie das aussieht bei mir mittwochs.
Also, Kalender.
Mittwochmorgen
...
Mittwoch.
Mittwoch geht los.
Also ich fahr nach Frankfurt am Mittwoch, dass ich so
so um
8, halb 9
so in dem Dreh bin ich in Frankfurt
bin ich im Büro.
Und da hab ich
als erstes mal
Bericht aus dem IT
Lenkungskreis.
Da gibt es
quasi
die heißesten News
was sich wieder ausgedacht wurde.
Danach hab ich
Daily Scrum
Projekt.
Also ich sag euch mal die Zeiten dabei.
Das geht los um 9.
Danach hab ich 9.30 Uhr
Daily Scrum Projekt.
Dann hab ich, kann ich jetzt nicht richtig
vorlesen, bla bla bla
Softwareanbieter
Support Meeting von irgendeinem
Laden, wo wir Software gekauft haben.
Wo wir uns ab und zu mal drüber austauschen, ob das scheiß funktioniert
oder nicht.
Aber wenn es nicht funktioniert sind die weird
drauf. Danach hab ich
Gruppenmeeting 10.30 Uhr
Dann hab ich 14 Uhr
Teammeeting und danach hab ich
15 Uhr Projekt
Sync und Surefix
So
Das ist ein ganzer
Tag nichts machen außer
mieten und nach Frankfurt fahren.
Glücklicherweise
Ja
meine andere
Tage sind auch voll gemiete.
Aber dadurch das ich hin und zurück fahren muss passiert an dem Tag noch weniger.
Glücklicherweise
Kann ich das so machen, dass ich
nach dem Gruppenmeeting abhaue.
Ja
Also das Gruppenmeeting ist 10.30 Uhr
bis
11.30 Uhr geht das?
Wie kann man bei dieser Menge
was hinbekommen? Gar nicht, gar nicht.
Aber wie gesagt ich bin da immer am meckern, dass es
auch zu viel ist, aber ich denk mir mittlerweile ist nicht mein Problem.
Die
Ja das Unternehmen möchte das.
So
Und mehr als meckern kann ich nicht.
Ich lass
mich auch für den ganzen Tag mieten bezahlen.
Da hab ich keine Schmerzen mit.
So
Und dann geh ich was essen
und nach dem Mittagessen
um 13 Uhr
so 13.05 Uhr oder so
hau ich schon wieder ab in Frankfurt
dass ich heimfahren kann
dass ich genau
am Bahnhof ankomme
wenn unser Teammeeting
losgeht und da
nehm ich remote dran teil
während ich heimlaufe vom Bahnhof.
Ob ich da vorm Rechner sitze oder nicht
ist vollkommen unerheblich.
Und danach mach ich im Anschluss noch
Austausch und
Surefix Sync
Ne wie heißt das Ding?
Austausch und Sync Surefix
fürs Projekt.
Dann bin ich in der Zwischenzeit heimgelaufen
sitz wieder am Rechner und mach da noch eine halbe Stunde.
Das
ist sehr angenehm
dass das dort so flexibel
möglich ist mit den Arbeitszeiten
also das muss man denen auch anrechnen
dass die nicht hoch anrechnen
meinem Arbeitgeber dass der nicht nur
geschwätzt hat
vorfällt sondern die Sache auch wirklich
einhält. Natürlich wurde
mir das beim Vorstellungsgespräch und sowas da auch
alles schön schmackhaft verkauft
wie gut das da gehandhabt wird und sowas
und dann muss man denen sagen hey
die haben nicht nur geschwätzt die machen es auch wirklich
das hab ich schon anders erlebt. Ja
also gerade beim letzten Laden die haben sehr viel
geschwätzt und haben eigentlich nichts davon gemacht
beziehungsweise haben ja wunder was
angekündigt haben es dann aber am Ende
im Sande verlaufen lassen das ist dann nicht so
also selbst der normale
ich fahr nach Frankfurt und miete mir
den Popo Wund Tag
selbst der ist halbwegs erträglich
weil ich zwischendrin heimfahren kann
in Ruhe heimlaufen kann quasi
mit dem Headset auf ein bisschen mieten und dann noch
vorm Rechner sitzen mieten und dann bin ich 15.30 Uhr
fertig kann direkt daheim
vom Rechner aufstehen
entweder ne Runde rennen oder ne Runde Fahrradfahren gehen
da kann man sich echt nicht
beschweren
das ist top
und an den anderen Tagen wo ich gar nicht nach Frankfurt muss
ist natürlich noch besser
ich futter mittlerweile fast immer am PC
Mittagessen
die Zeit schenk ich denen
dafür gehe ich
ab und zu mal morgens ne kleine Runde rennen
und sowas
das kommt so plus minus ungefähr
aufs gleiche raus
ich schreib mir dementsprechend auch nicht jeden
Minute auf
selbst wenn ich abends noch mal in Teams
was tippe oder schnell was nachgucke
ja
das heißt du arbeitest effektiv nur 2 Tage
einmal Büro und einen Tag nur Mieten
ne ne ne ne
das siehst du falsch
effektiv arbeite ich gar nicht
effektiv ist da gar nichts von
das ist alles andere als effektiv
also ich würde sagen
wirklich arbeiten kann ich in der Woche
vielleicht 4 Stunden oder so
4 oder 5 Stunden
und das sind
das sind eigentlich hauptsächlich die Stunden morgens
wo noch nichts los ist
weil ansonsten ist der ganze Tag
meistens voll mit irgendwelchem Gemiete
bist du der Meinung
das der agile Kram einen unproduktiver macht
ne
bin ich nicht
ich weiß das das Agile
kein allzu guten Ruf hat
aber ich bin der Meinung
das wenn das gut gemacht ist
und gut gemacht
heißt für mich
so wie es zu dem jeweiligen Team
und zu dem Unternehmen passt
dann ist das eine vollkommen
ja legit gescheite Arbeitsweise
und man kommt damit klar
wenn das ganze ausartet
mit
oh wir müssen agiler werden
und holen uns da irgendeinen Spezial Coach
und jetzt machen wir irgendwelche komischen
was gibts denn da sonst noch alles
irgendwelche komischen
Reviews
mit irgendwelchen Klebezetteln
worauf keiner Bock hat
dann ist das nicht effektiv
und dann ist das auch nervig
aber wenn das
gescheit gemacht ist
wenn das zu dem was man entwickelt
oder ja
produzieren soll
und zu dem Team und zu den Leuten passt
und zu dem jeweiligen Unternehmen passt
ist das vollkommen in Ordnung
und es funktioniert
ja du hast immer irgendwas
was besser funktionieren könnte
wenn man jetzt natürlich
dran schreiben will
aber das nicht machen möchte
dann ist das eigentlich
von Anfang an zum Scheitern verurteilt
genauso wie wenn
auf einmal der
Projektmanager das Scrum Master sein soll
oder sowas das kann ja nicht funktionieren
das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche
paar Schuhe die sich sogar
gegenseitig behindern
das geht nicht
und wenn man sowas sieht weiß man gleich schon
ok die wollen einfach nur agil draufschreiben
damit es sich cool anhört
damit am Hut haben sie aber nix
also so sehen meine Meetings nicht aus
meine Meetings
sehen aus
ich komme in den Teams Call rein
also auch wenn ich vor Ort bin sind die meisten
Meetings immer noch über Teams und so
ich komme in den Teams Call rein
also so ein
übergreifendes Meeting jetzt
ja nicht im Team oder so
ja also zum Beispiel
irgendein Service Meeting zu irgendeinem
mit irgendeinem
Benutzer
bei einem Service von uns
ja also das erste was ist ich komme da rein
das erste ist erstmal ok
bei irgendeinem funktioniert die Kamera nicht
bei irgendeinem ist das Mikrofon im Arsch
irgendeiner schreibt im Chat
könnt ihr mich hören
dann wird erstmal mindestens 10 Minuten Probleme gefixt
ich weiß nicht was die Leute immer machen
mit ihrem Setup
aber bei mir behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal
funktioniert zu 99%
seit meinem ersten Arbeitstag
ok
seit meinem ersten Arbeitstag war nicht Home Office
seit dem zweiten Arbeitstag alles perfekt
es funktioniert einfach
ich meine ich benutze auch das gleiche Equipment wie hier zum streamen
ja ich habe mein Headset dran
und ansonsten
ist alles richtig eingestellt
es geht einfach
ich teste noch nicht mal mehr ob alles funktioniert
die einzige Sache wo ich wirklich was testen würde ist
wenn ich irgendwas präsentieren soll
dann würde ich vorher mal gucken ob das alles funktioniert
gut es gibt
da muss ich gar nichts sagen
ich weiß auch nicht was bei den meisten Leuten los ist
und kennt ihr das
es gibt Leute die sind so unglaublich
langsam mit allem
so ein Meeting geht los
und
es gibt ja Leute die stehen immer noch drauf
wenn Protokolle geschrieben werden in Meetings
ich finde Meeting Protokolle sind mit das unsinnigste
überhaupt das überflüssigste was es gibt
niemand liest diese Dinger
das wird ja immer vorgeschoben so nach dem Motto
ja wenn mal einer nicht da war
dann kann er in das Protokoll gucken
einen Scheiß macht er
niemand hat jemals in das Protokoll geguckt
wenn er nicht da war
keiner macht das
sagt nicht keiner macht das aber
so gut wie keiner macht es
ich habe zumindest noch keinen erlebt
der es macht
ja und es ist dann
das geht dann teilweise so langsam
so ja XYZ Meeting startet jetzt
hallo Leute
wer ist denn heute mit dem Protokoll dran
ah
ich sehe hier
der
whatever ist dran
und da sagt er oh ah ich bin heute dran
wo war das denn nochmal
ja auf dem Share
ja auf welchem Share
auf eurem Share oder auf dem
auf dem anderen Share
ah ne warte mal ich schick dir mal einen Sharepoint Link
ok
ah ich mach das auf
ah wie kriege ich das jetzt in Word auf
hm wo ist das jetzt
ah ok dann erstmal Anwesenheit
gucken wer ist denn da machen wir da mal X hin
das dauert 10 Minuten
bis es losgeht nachdem es losgegangen ist
wisst ihr wie ich das mach
ich muss manchmal
ich muss manchmal tatsächlich auch Protokoll schreiben
wir haben immer noch auch wenn es auch irgendwie
unüberflüssig ist bei unserer Gruppenrunde
haben wir so ein Protokoll
ich mach das ich gucke im Vorfeld wer dran ist
wenn ich dran bin mach ich das Ding auf
und sobald das Meeting losgeht
share ich mein Bildschirm und sage Jungs auf gehts
Protokoll erster Punkt Zack Zack
dann sind wir unterwegs auch durch
das halte ich nicht aus die
dieses Schleppende
ja
aber ich habs aber auch noch nie
erlebt das irgendwie einem in den Strick draus
gedreht wurde so nach dem Motto er wusste es nicht
obwohl es im Teammeeting Protokoll stand
es weiß jeder
das da keiner rein guckt und außerdem
gute Chefs wissen sie müssen eh alles 5 mal
sagen das es alle Leute gehört haben
mein vorletzter
Chef hat mir mal erzählt
auf einem seiner Führungskräfteschulungen
hat ihm ein Coach erzählt
er müsse im Durchschnitt
eher neue Sachen 7 mal erwähnen
dass es alle mitbekommen haben
und das ist
gar nicht so also wenn man sich mal überlegt
das ist nicht unrealistisch
es fehlen immer Leute
die Leute hören nicht zu die Leute kommen zu spät rein
die Leute haben Audioprobleme
whatever
du musst das 7 mal sagen
dass du die Chance hast dass es
höchstwahrscheinlich alle die meisten
mitbekommen haben
und das ist durchaus realistisch
ein weiterer Grund warum ich auf sowas
überhaupt so 0,nix
gar keinen Bock habe
aber das finde ich auch gut
das habe ich
von Anfang an schon immer wenn es Thema war
meinem Chef erzählt und
der sieht das ein ja also in der alten
Firma war das so
mein Chef dort hat versucht immer
mir irgendwelche Karrieremöglichkeiten
nahezulegen so nach dem Motto ey
du könntest hier mal
dich als im Projekt versuchen und so
ich musste immer sagen nein ich will weder
Projektmanagement machen noch will ich irgendwie was leiten
geht mal weg mit dem Zeug
das hat mein aktueller Chef
sofort kapiert sehr nice
muss man sagen der ist da eh sehr auf Zack
also ich weiß gar nicht wie der sich das
alles merkt der hat irgendwie was weiß ich
15 Leute oder so die ihm den ganzen
Tag mit irgendwas zuschwätzen aber der merkt sich
das ich könnte
mir das nicht mal von 3 Leuten merken ja
aber der hat sich das
gemerkt der weiß genau
der Max hat keinen Bock auf irgendwelche
Führungsgeschichten oder Management Sachen
und dann kommt er
damit schon gar nicht mehr
so muss das sein
mal ganz davon
abgesehen
du verdienst zwar dort
wo ich arbeite ein bisschen mehr
wenn du
irgendwelche Management Sachen
übernimmst ja
aber ganz ehrlich du verdienst nicht so viel
mehr das ich mir den Stress geben würde
aber naja
Weiterbildung und so weiter schlägst du auch
ne nicht zwangsläufig da ging es ja auch nicht
drum es ging jetzt um irgendwelche
Weiterentwicklung in Form von
Projektleitungen oder
irgendwelche möchtest
du nicht nach keine Ahnung
Lissabon neuer
Teamleiter werden oder so Zeug
gar keinen Fall will
ich das machen
Weiterbildung wenn sie sinnvoll
sind ja
also schon mal keine Microsoft
Azure Schulung alle die ich da gemacht hab waren hochgradig
sinnlos soll ich
euch mal sagen was die beste Weiterbildung ist
die beste Weiterbildung ist
mich daheim an den Rechner setzen und irgendwas auszuprobieren
bis es funktioniert und daran rumzubasteln
besser als jede offizielle
Schulung und Weiterbildung
ich weiß danach besser Bescheid als
wenn ich einen offiziellen 5 Tageskurs
gemacht hätte
es muss aber auch was sein was mich interessiert
wenn es mich nicht interessiert dann kannst du mich
dazu natürlich nicht begeistern
wenn ich eine Festplatte mit dd und
def u random vollschreibe
müssen doch die
alten Daten nicht mehr
hergestellt werden können
ich muss doch nicht alles stundenlang schreddern lassen
ne musst du nicht
ich würde aber auch nicht u random
sondern einfach def zero benutzen
zum überschreiben
einfach mit 0 überschreiben und gut ist
du musst nicht u random nehmen
def zero reicht
dd if def zero
of
def sda
block size 4k
und gibby
die können danach nicht mehr hergestellt werden
wenn du mit der Festplatte auch
wirklich Festplatte meinst
du musst nicht stundenlang schreddern
du musst das einmal von Anfang bis Ende
überschreiben lassen mit 0 und gut ist
dann kannst du nichts sinnvoll wiederherstellen
bei heutigen Festplatten
da ist die Dichte einfach zu groß
auf den Dingern gibt es auch schon zig Tests dafür
natürlich kannst du super
extra sicher sein und
75 mal random überschreiben
aber was sonst
einmal mit 0 überschreiben reicht übrigens
ein weiterer Grund dafür seine Festplatte von Anfang
an voll zu verschlüsseln
weil dann kannst du sie einfach ohne zu nullen
in den Müll schmeißen und keiner kann was mit anfangen
oder einmal nullen und
die Sache ist eh gelaufen
ähm wenn es eine SSD ist
würde ich das anders machen
bei einer SSD
würde ich ein
ähm
je nachdem wie es der Hersteller nennt
so eine Art
Factory Reset machen
weil du kannst bei SSDs
also viele SSDs
verschlüsseln
und du kannst quasi diesen Verschlüsselungskey
löschen lassen
bei manchen läuft das unter
unter Werksreset oder so Secure Erase
genau ja ich glaube das ist der korrekte
der korrekte das korrekte
Bezeichnung dafür Secure Erase
du kannst natürlich trotzdem
danach das Ding nochmal mit 0 überschreiben
aber bei SSDs ist es
halt ein bisschen anders wie bei Festplatten
bei Festplatten schreibst du halt wirklich von Anfang bis Ende
durch bis in einen ganz kleinen Bereich
bei SSDs hast du dann
wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch
ähm
was heißt Re-Leveling
auf Deutsch
Verbrauchsverteilung oder sowas
nicht wirklich
ich meine nicht die Nivellierung
von Verschleiß
naja warum eigentlich
nicht
aber wahrscheinlich gibt es
eine schönere Übersetzung
bei SSDs weißt du ja nicht so genau
wenn du voll geschrieben hast ob du wirklich voll geschrieben hast
das heißt Secure Erase
ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll
natürlich kannst du davor und danach nochmal Def Zero machen
um extra sicher zu sein
Secure Erase geht auch schnell
weil Secure Erase im Endeffekt ja nur
den Encryption Key löscht
ich glaube ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was genau Secure Erase macht
aber ich glaube
den Encryption Key einfach neu
generieren
ich rede nicht von Zugriffsteilen
gleichmäßige Nutzung
das ist ein schönes Wort dafür ja
du kannst das Ding natürlich auch
physisch zerstören
das geht auch
du kannst es durchbohren
Google hat so eine Presse
für Datenträger
die stanzt dann so ein Loch rein
moin bim
aber sowas hat man ja daheim in der Regel nicht
wer hat eine Storage Vernichtungs
Stanzmaschine daheim
Toffifee
tisch
jetzt so rum
danke für den Sub
massive Subscribers
du hast sogar 3
was Storage Vernichtungs
Stanzmaschinen
aus Lego
Radiosignal
danke für den Sub
hat dein Opa keine Bohrmaschine
in seiner Werkstatt
also
mein Opa den gibt es schon eine Weile nicht mehr
ich hätte zur Not in meiner Werkstatt
eine Bohrmaschine
wahrscheinlich würde ich es einfach mit dem Akkuschrauber
machen weil die Dinger sind ja nicht sonderlich
im Prinzip einfach nur pläscht
richtig ein Bohrer dran und fertig
aber ich brauche das nicht
weil meine Datenträger einfach von der
allerersten Verwendung an voll verschlüsselt sind
das heißt ich kann die Dinger nehmen
in den Müll schmeißen und niemand kann damit was anfangen
ey Max du hattest in einem
deiner letzten Streams erwähnt dass einige
der externen Kollegen von großen Firmen wohl
Kommunikationsseminare besucht haben
habe ich das in welchem Kontext
also ja bestimmt
bestimmt haben die das
hast du sowas auch mal gemacht
oder weißt du wie die heißen
meistens unter irgendwas mit Softskills
irgendwas mit Softskills heißt
das dann
gibt es in allen nur erdenklichen
Ausprägungen diese
Kurse und Seminare
aber meistens heißt das
irgendwas als Überschrift mit Softskills
ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt keinen konkreten
Namen
was nimmst du für deine SSD
bzw HDD Verschlüsselung
VeraCrypt unter
Windows und
ganz normal Lux unter Linux
gibt es ja nicht so viel Auswahl
und gut unter Windows gibt es neben VeraCrypt auch keine Auswahl
es gibt BitLocker aber BitLocker traue ich
nicht über den Weg
das erste was ich damals über BitLocker gelesen habe war dass man
irgendwie mit einer Passwort Recovery seine Festplatte
wieder entschlüsseln kann da habe ich mir gedacht okay
kann keine ordentliche Verschlüsselung
sein wenn man das resetten kann
das könnt ihr euch mal prinzipiell merken
sobald du was verschlüsselst
und irgendjemand bietet dir eine Recovery
Möglichkeit an
ist es Kacke
ist es Dreck und taugt nix
eine ordentliche Verschlüsselung bedeutet
Passwort weg
oder sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt Passwort
Key weg gleich Daten weg
so muss das sein alles andere ist
Beschiss du hast gemeint dass die Leute
die bei Google arbeiten eine gute
ja das stimmt ja das ist richtig
also das merkst
du bei den gut aber hey
wisst ihr mit welchen Google Leuten ich zu tun
habe das sind irgendwelche
Semitechnik
begeisterte Leute sondern hauptsächlich irgendwelche
Marketing und Verkaufsleute
die da am Start sind bei uns
und die ja die
können gut schwätzen
VeraCrypt ist TrueCrypt
TrueCrypt gibt es nicht mehr
VeraCrypt ist der TrueCrypt Nachfolger
bei einem Gewerbung bei einem
Bewerbungsgespräch ging es mal ums Gehalt
und ich habe eine Spanne angegeben die fragten dann
wovon die Zahlen denn abhängen
ich sagte kommt drauf an wieviel
ja
ist
ist ehrlich geantwortet je nachdem
wie die drauf sind
sind das dann gut oder schlecht
wie kam das an
also ich
ich find's lustig aber
ich bin ja auch kein
Personalabteilungsmitarbeiter
also bei mir wär's gut angekommen
das heißt aber das heißt ja nix
also bei Gehaltsspanne muss ich immer noch an die
Story von meinem
ehemaligen und jetzt wieder Arbeitskollege
denken der sich
beworben hat bei
einem Laden die haben ihm gesagt das ist ne
keine Ahnung Senior
Support
Blablup Stelle
sie bezahlen 95k im Jahr
hat er sich beworben
Bewerbungsprozess durchgemacht erste Runde
zweite Runde dritte Runde in der dritten Runde
musste er sogar Supportfälle mit denen
am Telefon durchspielen
so nach dem Motto
sie bekommen hier nen Ticket
Kunde droht mit Eskalation
bla bla bla
dann musste er denen genau erklären wie er diesen Fall bearbeiten würde
und sowas
und am Ende waren sie sich einig
und es wurde ihm auch
mehrfach bestätigt
dass es eben diese Gehaltsspanne gibt
für diesen Job ja also 95k
plus
und dann waren die sich einig
und irgendwann haben sie sich bei ihm gemeldet
wo sie gesagt haben ja
es gibt jetzt doch nur
75k
ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher
was die sich
ach ja ich weiß was für ne Ausrede war
ich weiß was für ne Ausrede war
sie haben gesagt ja das Budget gibt doch keine
Seniorposition mehr her
und dann habe ich mir gedacht ja
da fuck alter dann überlegt euch das doch
vorher ihr könnt doch nicht einen
Bewerbungsprozess durchmachen lassen
und dann sagen ja Moment die Stelle gibt es doch gar nicht
und dann denke ich mir so
was erwarten die denn dann eigentlich
meinen die wirklich
das irgendjemand sagt oh jetzt habe ich euch
schon so gut kennengelernt und ich fand es
so toll jetzt arbeite ich auch für
keine Ahnung 20-30k weniger
es ist doch eher
umgedreht wenn du schon bevor im Vertrag
vor der Unterschrift so verarscht wirst
gehst du doch da im Leben nicht hin oder
ja nur weil das
nur weil das in dem
in dem Job
in der Jobbezeichnung drin steht heißt es ja nicht
dass es ein
First Level Support
Mitarbeiter ist der
den Leuten erklärt wie sie ihren Monitor
einschalten
das richtige dick Move ja
Jebcock Move ist das
aber
eigentlich hätte man das denen in Rechnung
stellen sollen
aber auf der anderen Seite
auf der anderen Seite eigentlich
gut dass das nicht geklappt hat weil
jetzt
arbeitet er bei mir und
wir können regelmäßig
Mittagessen
uns voll fressen
zusammen
stelle ich mir geil vor eine Abmahnung
einer Firma zu schicken bei der man nicht arbeitet
für was willst du die abmahnen
ich mahne euch schon mal ab falls ich
jemals bei euch anfangen werde
reine Netzwerkplanung
Installation
Instandhaltung
ist jetzt trotzdem sehr allgemein oder
aber wenn man Netzwerksachen
gerne macht ist das pock
du hättest bestimmt letztens wo wir uns
gefragt haben sofort aus dem Kopf gewusst
was die zweite Schicht des OSI Modells ist oder
ich musste ein bisschen überlegen
und ich hab schon
wieder vergessen Leute
ah Datalink
Datalink oder?
Datalink
Leute
in der letzten Firma wo ich es geschafft habe
mit dem gleichen
Kollege von dem ich gerade euch erzählt habe
wie die Bewerbung lief
der arbeitet dort ja auch im Support
daher kannte ich den übrigens
ich habe eine Weile im gleichen Großraumbüro
gehockt wo auch unsere Supportleute
gehockt haben die haben ein bisschen
abgesetzt oder wie soll man sagen
in so einem kleinen eigenen Bereich
gehockt aber ich kannte den ja daher
und
ich hab von dem auch öfters Storys gehört
mein letzter Arbeitgeber hat es
innerhalb von
ich weiß nicht ich sag jetzt mal 6
oder 7 Jahre wie lang der dort war
nicht geschafft
dass die
Abrechnungen richtig waren
die mussten die Leute
weil das war ein bisschen ein Sonderfall
dadurch das die im Support gearbeitet haben
mussten die es war kein reiner Support
das war eher so ein Leitstand
kann man das so sagen
quasi Ansprechpartner
bei Störungen und
also auch inklusive Systemüberwachung
sowas war das
in der Richtung was der da gemacht hat
und
dadurch das die dann halt auch nachts
dort waren vor Ort
die waren 24 7 besetzt
hat es die Personalabteilung bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber
wirklich 7 Jahre
in Folge nicht hinbekommen das die Abrechnungen
gestimmt haben die mussten jeden
Monat über 7 Jahre
oder länger manche das gab es ja noch länger
jeden ihrer
Abrechnungen kontrollieren und das lief
dann darauf raus das die Leute sich eine Excel Tabelle
gemacht haben um das gegen zu rechnen
was denn da in der offiziellen
ey das hätte mich so abgefuckt
schon nach dem ersten halben Jahr
also generell hätte mich Schichtarbeit und Nachtschicht
schon so abgefuckt das ich es nicht gemacht hätte aber
das hätte mich schon so abgefuckt
das ich es wahrscheinlich nicht länger als ein halbes Jahr ausgehalten hätte
also das war echt absolutes
Armutszeugnis von denen
aber generell war die Personalabteilung
da echt etwas
besonders
jeden Monat
mussten die das kontrollieren ja es gab auch
Monate da hat das gestimmt es heißt nicht das es
jeden Monat falsch war die mussten es jeden Monat
kontrollieren weil es potenziell falsch sein
konnte und dass es öfters falsch
war
ja genau sowas war das genau
richtig
ein Network Operations Center
hieß es nicht war es
auch nicht direkt sondern
aber sowas in der Richtung
mit ganz viel Monitoring
Wänden und
Systemüberwachung
Systemstatus und
Ticketeingang wenn irgendwas ist sowas
sowas war das genau also wie gesagt es war
kein Support in Form von
Hilfe beim Monitor geht nicht
mehr an die konnten sich dann auch wenn
irgendwas reingekommen ist auch schon
quasi auf den Produktivsystem einloggen
und gucken was ist denn da kaputt
müssen wir denn jetzt wirklich
irgendjemand von den Linux Leuten nachts um
3 Uhr anrufen und sowas also das war
jetzt keine Noobs die da gehockt haben
gibt es eigentlich noch das alte Ticket
bei dir auf der alten Arbeit das mit dem
uralt Red Hat das man nicht upgraden
ok lass mal überlegen
welches war das
du meinst das
du meinst das Red Hat 5
ne das Red Hat 6
als Red Hat 5 ne das Red Hat
6 als Red Hat 4 getarnt
meinst du das meinst du
das war so ein
wahren Wirtschaftssystem so ein altes
das meinst du
ich gehe davon aus dass es das noch
gibt ja
mich würde sehr wundern wenn es weg ist
also ich weiß es nicht
ich bin jetzt ja schon über ein Jahr da weg
ich würde drauf tippen
dass es das noch gibt ja
Demian 5 das ist auch
5 war das Edge
ne Edge war 4
oder
Jessie war das Jessie ist 5 war mal
Demian das ist richtig alt
Lenny
Jessie war 8
Edge war 4
genau Lenny
wann kam
das raus
naja ist ja nur 15 Jahre
alt ja
und Fun Fact das System
von dem hier der RF Programmer spricht
das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt
das war
ein Red Hat 6 ihr könnt euch überlegen
das war damals schon alt
aber das war ein Red Hat 6
wo in der Versionsdatei
drinne stand das es ein Red Hat 4 war
weil selbst
damals Red Hat 6 noch zu neu war
und die Software in diese Versionsdatei
reingeguckt hat und ist nicht gestartet
wenn da was neueres als Red Hat 4 drinne steht
also man musste unter dem Red Hat 6
die Versionsdatei patchen also
etc Red Hat Release oder was es sonst noch gibt
patchen das da Red Hat 4 drinne steht
ja
warum ich mir das merken kann das Demian 4
Edge ist das war mein erstes
Demian
hier habe ich angefangen mit Demian
Edge
Saatch hatte ich auch noch
aber ich habe gerade so
umgeschaltet ich habe
gerade angefangen mich mit Demian und
ein bisschen tiefgreifender dann auch mit Linux
zu beschäftigen
als Saatch als Edge schon
Testing und nahe Stable war
da habe ich dann angefangen
mich auch mal mit ich meine ich
Linux Sachen habe ich vorher schon gemacht
aber so richtig mit Linux auf dem Server
ja davor waren das irgendwelche Spielereien
habe ich angefangen mich hier so 2006
2007 mit zu beschäftigen
und deswegen kann ich
mir merken das Edge war 4
ja das weiß ich noch
danach kriege ich das ganze nicht
mehr zusammen
und wer sich jetzt fragt sorry for lag
und wer sich jetzt fragt wie diese
woher diese Namen kommen von den Demian
Releases das sind alles Toy Story
Characters
Woody ist der Cowboy Saatch ist der
der Soldat
Edge weiß ich nicht Lenny weiß ich auch nicht
Jesse ist
die Cowboy Frau
Wheezy ist das
ist Wheezy nicht der Hund
ne Buster
Buster ist der Hund
ähm
Trixie
zumindest sind das Toy Story Namen
und nachdem es glaube ich mittlerweile
4 oder so Toy Story Filme gibt
gehen denen wahrscheinlich auch die Codenamen
in nächster Zeit nicht aus
das gab es tatsächlich
das gab es noch nicht
gibt es bestimmt auch mal irgendwann
sagt denen gehen die
denen gehen die Namen nicht aus
ja das letzte Video
war vor glaube ich 170 Tagen
oder so also da gibt es auch
Videos so einmal im Jahr oder so
keck wait
oh Leute ich werd müde ey
es ist ja auch bald
schon Bett Zeit
das war heute eher so ne spontane Geschichte
was müssen wir eigentlich als nächstes machen
ich glaube als nächstes müssen wir Blazer tatsächlich
ausprobieren
weil ich das geflamed habe
und ich immer noch der Meinung bin es taugt nix
da muss ich jetzt nen Stream machen
wo ich mir Blazer angucke und mein Fazit steht jetzt schon fest
ich mag Blazer nicht
und ich werde wahrscheinlich am Ende des Streams
feststellen das Blazer nix taugt
ich mein
es gab auch schon Sachen
da dachte ich die taugen nix
und die waren dann gar nicht schlecht
vielleicht ist es ja ich glaub's aber nicht
vielleicht ist es aber auch sowas
ich
ich gehe nicht davon aus ehrlich gesagt
wisst ihr was
grad sehr unangenehm ist
ich hab Hunger
das ist eine ganz schlechte Uhrzeit
zum Hunger haben
ich ess glaub ich noch ein paar Salz
paar so Salzbrezel
die sind
nicht so heftig und
kann man sich ein paar rein hauen
es ist eh
seit ich viel Sport mache
hab ich so viel Hunger
ich bin so krass am fressen
aber ich nehm nicht zu
das gleicht sich irgendwie aus
ich nehm sogar eher ein bisschen ab
Salzbrezel
können wir mit dir auch so
random Sachen machen
wir haben doch schon so viele
random Sachen gemacht
Proxmox haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt
aber es ist schon ein bisschen her
es gibt so ein paar Sachen
die find ich cool
aber hab ich keinen Anwendungszweck für
bei mir daheim da ist Proxmox gehört dann nicht dazu
es gibt ein paar Sachen
die
guck ich mir immer wieder an
und die find ich immer wieder kacke
Open Media World zum Beispiel
oder
Nextcloud
oder Wayland
wenns denn dann mal funktionieren würde
also hast du jetzt einfach normal Hunger
ja ich hab einfach normal Hunger
CC++
ja das mach ich auch immer wieder
wobei gegen C hab ich nix
das
C++ ja das mach ich auch immer wieder
und find's jedes mal wieder kacke
soll ich euch mal ein Beispiel
ich hatte heute ein schönes Beispiel
ich hatte
erklärt mir mal für Normalsterbliche
was es tut
und nachdem letztens jemand gesagt hat
Max diese Seite hier die taugt ja gar nix
dann
gehen wir jetzt einfach mal
auf die angeblich verständlichere Seite
die ist auch verständlicher
aber
the fuck
wie kompliziert kann man etwas machen
bitteschön
also von der Idee her dachte ich eigentlich
remove if
sagst du hey ich hab hier
ne Liste mit Elementen
und
ich entferne alles
wo das if
true ist
ja also ganz normale Filterfunktionen
im Endeffekt für ne Liste
ist es aber nicht
das ist C++ in C++ ist es nicht so einfach
wenn ihr das hier gelesen habt
habt ihr kein klasse Schimmer was
remove if macht
also das Beispiel
das Beispiel ist schon wieder grausam
remove if
remove if würde ich sagen ist im Endeffekt
ein bisschen sowas wie Filter
ja würde man vermuten
bisschen sowas wie
Array Filter in JavaScript
könnte man denken
könnte man vermuten aber nein
ist es nicht es ist
passt auf haltet euch fest
transforms the range first last
warum auch immer das so komisch mit Klammern und der Ecke
into a range
with all the elements for which
predicate returns true
removed and
moment moment
and returns an iterate to the new end of the range
the function cannot alter
the properties of the object
containing the range of
wie kompliziert kann man es machen
ich hab ne Liste
ich will Elemente entfernen wo die Bedingung true ist
wie kompliziert
wie fucking kompliziert kann man es eigentlich machen
mit dem neuen Iterator
ja aber warum
was ist das
das versteht
das versteht doch keine Sau
here the relative order of the elements
not removed is preserved
while the elements between the results left are valid without
but unspecified
state
was
, was soll das überhaupt
warum
warum gibt es nicht ne Funktion
wie, wie guck mal
in javascript würde es so funktionieren
javascript auch keine schöne Sprache
in javascript würdest du sagen
here array mit den Elementen 1,2,3,4,5 drin
the fuck was
alter was ist mit meiner shell los
ok ok node
so in node in javascript
in javascript würdest du nimmst
array sagst ist es überhaupt Filter
ach ne
ok
heißt das nicht Filter
Map ne doch
warum geht das nicht
chat javascript warum findest du es nicht
geht doch
so
so würde man das in javascript machen
in javascript würdest du zum Beispiel sagen
jedes Element was größer
keine Ahnung jedes Element was größer als 2 ist
und dann bleibt am Ende noch 3,4,5 übrig
das kann so easy sein
aber nein
nein nein nein
sowas einfaches wie ein Filter
ne Elemente filtern
aus dem Vektor an der Liste
so einfach geht es in C++ nicht
da braucht man sowas komplett
unverständliches
dafür
guckt euch das mal an
allein schon das Beispiel
was ist mit euch los
remove if
begin end
ok hier ist die Funktion
es ist quasi gerade
ein neues Array oder so
sondern es gibt einen Iterator
WTF
wer denkt sich diese Scheiße aus
wie bescheuert sind die Leute
die in diesem Standard Gremium sitzen
sich sowas auszudenken
das ist so unverständlich
und so
und so unintuitiv
du bist richtig
du hast ne Vorschleife
selbst schneller gebaut als das
du hast mit einer normalen Vorschleife
das schneller gefiltert
als damit
vor allem hast du am Ende dann ne Liste
mit der du was anfangen kannst
und die filtert man in C
mit ner Vorschleife
in C würdest du es einfach von Hand machen
wie übrigens in Go
auch
weil die Go Leute was das angeht
sehr minimalistisch sind
die Go Leute haben sich auch gedacht
nee
ne Filterfunktion für nen Array
das braucht man nicht
mach ne Vorschleife am besten nicht
3 nested Vorschleifen
das ist übrigens ein Vorschlag der kommt öfters von
wie nennen sich eigentlich Go
Go Programmierer
Goffers
oder sowas
in Rust geht das sehr schön
in Rust ist das überhaupt kein Problem
ich
ich kann aus dem Kopf
keine Rust
Rust Syntax
aber in Rust würdest du sowas machen
Filter
Größer 2
Irgendwie sowas würdest du in Rust machen
in Rust wäre das
eigentlich ganz schön lesbar
in Rust kannst du dir sogar noch aussuchen
ob du die ursprüngliche Liste
ändern möchtest oder ob du ne Kopie davon
ändern möchtest und ne neue Liste anlegst
das ist also
keine Ahnung was mit denen los ist
das kann durchaus sein
relativ vieles wurde sich von Lisp abgeguckt
manche Sprachen
haben sich auch angeguckt dass man
30 Milliarden Klammern
aneinander braucht
also das hier ist bestimmt gültiger Lisp Code
glaube ich
weiß nicht was das macht aber das passt
bestimmt den Lisp Syntax
den Syntax Check
welches Betriebssystem was für eine Konsole ist
das Arch by the way
allein schon die Frage
was sonst
by the way
Arch Linux
natürlich
use ich Arch
steht das hier irgendwo
eh ja
Westterm ist das
meiner Meinung nach
das beste Terminal was es zur Zeit unter
Linux gibt
alles andere kann einpacken
auch Kitty
Kitty kann einpacken weil der Kitty Autor so weird champ ist
gegenüber TMAX Nutzung
und in Westterm funktioniert das einfach
ah wenn du Endeavor verwendest kannst du
darf man Chat
benutzt man Arch by the way
ich würde sagen
ja macht man
weil Manjaro nicht
Manjaro ist kein Arch by the way
weil Manjaro hat nochmal
eigene Repos
aber Endeavor würde ich sagen
geht als Arch Linux durch
du hast schonmal das richtige ausgesucht
weil die coolen Leute
heutzutage
auf NixOS stehen genau
wobei
warum eigentlich NixOS
nicht einfach Arch mit dem Nix Package Manager
dann hat man doch die ganzen
Hackermans Zeug in einem
Max machst du bei deinem Gehalt
eigentlich eine Steuererklärung
ne ich habe einen Steuerberater
der die Steuererklärung macht
also nicht selbst
krieg ich Anfälle wenn ich das selbst machen muss
zumal ich es nicht nur für mich selbst machen muss
sondern auch für meine Firma noch machen muss
jetzt sind
nicht krass krass Business und hier
komm in die Gruppe
nicht dass ich damit viel Kohle mache aber trotzdem ist das steuerlich
extra nochmal
gesondert zu betrachten
und deswegen habe ich
seitdem ich das gegründet habe
den Steuerberater und der macht das seitdem
was auch gut ist
weil vor 2 Jahren
oder so hatte ich so eine
random Finanzamt Prüfung
stichprobenartig da hat man Pech
und das fällt manchmal auf ein
und da musste
ich mich glücklicherweise nicht drum kümmern
sondern es hat alles mein Steuerberater gemacht
ich werde durchgedreht ey wenn die irgendwelche Dokumente von mir haben
die ich irgendwo sonst wo liegen habe
ich will jetzt nicht sagen
aber
sonderlich gut hast du nicht aufgepasst oder
mich wunderts
dass dem Chat noch keiner mal aufgefallen ist
was
was genau ist eine if Schleife
ok
man könnte sagen
dass while
x2
dass das eine if Schleife ist ok
aber das ist damit wahrscheinlich nicht gemeint
also
was ihr so richtig gemacht habt
ist halt für den Arsch
aber man muss insofern korrekt sein
es gibt keine if Schleifen
da gibt es sogar eine Seite
genau
if Statement lasse ich mir auch gefallen
wobei eine Schleife auch ein Statement
sein kann
aber komm nicht auf die Idee
in deiner Abschlussprüfung
was von einer if Schleife zu erzählen
du kannst
if Statement sagen meinetwegen
abfrage
und Schleife
aber nicht beides in Kombination
weil das
gibt keinen Sinn
Chatge ich gebe mir jetzt noch ein paar
Salzbrezel
ok ihr habt ja
ihr könnt euch das jetzt aussuchen
soll ich noch 10 Minuten on bleiben
und wollen wir
weiter nochmal eine Viertelstunde schwätzen
während ich meine Salzbrezel fresse
oder soll ich
off gehen und morgen wiederkommen
ja
das mit einem Komma dazwischen ist ok
ITSE
was ist denn ITSE
IT-Systemelektroniker
aha das ist ja eine richtig oldschool Ausbildung
die gab es schon vor dem FISI
ich gehe doch jetzt nicht mehr laufen
um 21.47
da bin ich ja noch wacher als wenn ich
über C++ geraged habe
if Verzweigung
das ist natürlich auch sehr schön
ja das gefällt mir auch
if Verzweigung
das ist nice
das habe ich so selten selten gehört
gefällt mir eigentlich am besten
gefällt mir noch besser als if Abfrage
if Verzweigung
ich warte drauf bis die Leute das jetzt komplett in Deutsch machen
wenn Verzweigung
oder so was
oder falls
falls Verzweigung
so Leute ich gehe jetzt mir noch ein paar Salzbrezel holen
und dann hören wir uns morgen
oder die Tage bis dann machts gut
spontaner Stream
bis dann machts gut
CU